Sudán al borde de una gran crisis
humanitaria Es solo el quinto día de
combates en jartum pero los residentes
de la capital ya experimentan el pánico
por la falta de servicios básicos a raíz
de los enfrentamientos entre el ejército
y las FARC el suministro de agua y luz
han sido cortados en ciertas partes de
la ciudad además muchos comercios han
cerrado sus puertas por el miedo a ser
objeto de la violencia lo que ha
provocado un desabasto en medicamentos e
insumos básicos
Desafortunadamente la capital harton
está colapsada desde el sábado pasado
Aquí no hay agua en las tuberías ni en
los depósitos el agua almacenada está
casi agotada
a pesar de la urgencia por ayuda las
organizaciones humanitarias se
encuentran imposibilitadas para actuar
Naciones Unidas ha denunciado agresiones
y violencia sexual en contra de
trabajadores humanitarios Durante los
combates en jartum además la movilidad
de asistencia es sumamente compleja
consecuencia del constante intercambio
bélico entre ambos bandos
la verdad es que en estos momentos es
casi imposible prestar ninguna
asistencia humanitaria en jartum y sus
alrededores recibimos llamadas de
diversas organizaciones y personas
atrapadas pidiendo que las evacuen desde
hace cuatro días la gente no tiene agua
ni comida y la electricidad ha sido
totalmente desconectada en algunos
lugares
en 2022 Sudán se posicionó en el lugar
172 en el índice de desarrollo humano
uno de los más bajos del mundo el
conflicto actual podría acentuar esta
condición y generar una nueva crisis
humanitaria en una nación africana